>>> THREE DAY AFTER THE MASSACRE
IN TEXAS, THE ANNUAL CONVENTION
IS UNDERWAY IN TEXAS.
CNN'S CHIEF NATIONAL AFFAIR JEFF
ZELS,
JEFF ZELENY, IS WITH US.
WHAT DID THE GOVERNOR SAY?
>> Reporter: HE STARTED BY
READING THE NAMES OF THE
VICTIMS.
LITERALLY IN THE NEXT BREATH,
THE FORMER PRESIDENT WENT ONTO
BLAME THE SHOOTING ON ANYTHING
OTHER THAN GUNS.
THE PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT
SAFETY IN SCHOOLS AND MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES AND TAKE A BIT
OF A CRACK OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE MONEY
SENT TO UKRAINE.
THE PRESIDENT SQUARELY AND
CLEARLY BEHIND THE NRA IN HIS
ADDRESS TONIGHT.
>> THE EXISTENCE OF EVIL IN OUR
WORLD IS NOT A REASON TO ARM
LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS IN RESPONSE
TO EVIL.
POLITICIANS SEEKING TO EXPLOIT
THE TEARS OF SOBBING FAMILIES TO
INCREASE THEIR OWN POWER AND
TAKE OUR WAY OUR OWN
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
>> Reporter: WITH THOUSANDS OF
NRA MEMBERS GATHERING HERE,
LITERALLY LESS THAN 300 MILES
FROM UVALDE, THERE WERE
THOUSANDS OF PROTESTERS OUTSIDE
THE CONVENTION, SHOWING HOW
ENTRENCHED THIS DEBATE IS IN
AMERICA.
NO SOLUTIONS HERE.
>> JEFF ZELENY IN HOUSTON, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH JOHN KASICH
AND KIRSTEN POWERS.
GOVERNOR JOHN KASICH.
>> GIVE ME A BREAK, HE'S AT THE
NRA CONVENTION.
WE HAVE SO MANY GUNS IN THIS
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW AND THERE IS
NO REASON FOR THIS PROLIFERATION
AND NOW PEOPLE ARE GOING THE
SAY, WELL, WE NEED MORE GUNS AND
MORE GUNS CAN BE SAFER.
THAT'S NOT RATIONAL.
IT IS RIDICULOUS.
AS I LISTEN TO HIM START TO
CRITICIZE THE CYNICAL
POLITICIANS AND ALL THAT, IT
REMINDED ME WHY I SPENT MY WHOLE
TIME TRYING TO OPPOSE HIM FOR
PRESIDENT IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THAT TERRIBLE MESSAGE AND IT
SHOULD BE A MESSAGE BRINGING
EVERYBODY TOGETHER AND NOT
DIVIDE US.
I DON'T KNOW ANYBODY IN THIS
COUNTRY DOES NOT THINK WE HAVE A
PROBLEM BECAUSE WE HAVE TOO MANY
GUNS.
ONE THING I WILL SAY THAT HE'S
RIGHT ABOUT IS MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES.
NOT JUST FOR ADULTS BUT FOR OUR
CHILDREN AS WELL.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
SERIOUS AND IT IS NOT JUST
MONEY, WE NEED THE BUILD A
NETWORK WITH PEDIATRICIANS AND
WITH DOCTORS THAT WE SEE AND OUR
PRIMARY CARE DOCTORS.
WE NEED TO GET PEOPLE HELP.
THIS WAS THE CASE OF WHAT THIS
GUY WAS DOING AND THE BEHAVIOR
HE WAS ENGAGED IN WITH ANIMALS.
THAT WAS A FIRST SIGN THAT HE
HAD TROUBLE.
NOBODY DID ANYTHING.
THERE HAS TO BE A COMPREHENSIVE
PLAN ON THAT AND WHAT HE SHOULD
HAVE MENTIONED IS A RED FLAG
LAW.
IF YOU NO E SOMEBODY THAT HAS A
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEM, YOU WOULD
TAKE THEIR GUN AWAY.
HE NEVER SAID THAT.
HE'S THERE TRYING TO SUCK UP
VOTES.
THAT WAS WHAT IT WAS ABOUT.
>> AND MONEY AS WELL.
HE'S NOT GOING TO CROSS THE NRA.
KIRSTEN POWERS, WHAT THOUGHTS
ARE GOING THROUGH YOUR MIND AS
YOU ARE HEARING ALL THIS?
>> WELL, JUST YOU KNOW, A LITTLE
BIT OF HIS SPEECH THAT I WAS
ABLE TO READ BEFORE WE CAME ON.
HE'S DOING WHAT THE NRA LIKES TO
DO WHICH IS POINT TO EVERY
SINGLE THING EXCEPT FOR THE GUN.
IT IS USUALLY THE SAME GUN
THAT'S USED WHEN EVER WE HAVE
THESE MASSACRES.
YES, MENTAL HEALTH IS AN ISSUE
IN THIS COUNTRY AND SEPARATE
FROM GUN VIOLENCE.
WE NEED TO TAKE IT SERIOUSLY
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING.
THERE ARE MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE IN
OTHER COUNTRIES.
THE DIFFERENCE IS OTHER
COUNTRIES DON'T ARM THEM WITH
SEMIAUTOMATIC WEAPONS.
THERE ARE THINGS THAT COULD BE
DONE.
I SHOULD MENTION THAT DONALD
TRUMP ALSO BLAMED BROKEN
FAMILIES FOR THIS?
HE'S BEEN DIVORCED TWICE.
THE PROBLEM IS THE GUNS.
WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING TO KEEP
THESE GUNS OUT OF THE HANDS OF
DANGEROUS PEOPLE AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THEY CAN DO IMMEDIATELY
WOULD BE RAISE THE AGE TO
PURCHASE A GUN BECAUSE MOST
VIOLENCE WITH GUNS ARE COMMITTED
BY YOUNG MEN BETWEEN THE AGE OF
18 OR 21 OR WHATEVER.
RAISE THE AGE TO 21 WOULD BE ONE
AND WE CAN DO IT RIGHT AWAY.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> COMPREHENSIVE BACKGROUND
CHECKS, THAT'S ANOTHER THING
THAT SHOULD BE DONE.
IN 1994, I VOTED FOR ASSAULT
WEAPON BAN.
I RAN FOR REELECTION AND I WON.
I RAN FOR GOVERNOR IN 2010 AND
THE NRA WENT AFTER ME FROM ONE
PART OF OHIO TO THE OTHER.
GUESS WHAT?
THEY LOST THAT ONE, TOO.
TO POLITICIANS WHO WOR